>> Sandra: SENATE MAJORITY
LEADER MITCH McCONNELL CALLING
LAWMAKERS BACK ON MONDAY WHILE
SOME ARE WORRIED THAT THEY WILL
NOT BE PROTECTED FROM THE
CORONAVIRUS WE’VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT THIS AND THERE ARE
QUESTIONS FROM SOME LAWMAKERS
THEMSELVES OVER WHETHER THIS IS
THE RIGHT TIME.
>> THAT’S RIGHT, THERE IS A LOT
OF CONSTERNATION IN ONE OF THE
REASONS IS BECAUSE THE REGION
HAD 2,000 NEW CASES ON THURSDAY.
WASHINGTON, D.C., ITSELF HAD THE
DEADLIEST DAY YET WITH
CORONAVIRUS, 19 DEATHS IN THE
DISTRICT OF COLUMBIA.
MITCH McCONNELL HAS NOT SAID
WHETHER OR NOT HE CONSULTED WITH
A CAPITAL ATTENDING PHYSICIAN OR
IF THE CAPITAL ATTENDING
PHYSICIAN GAVE HIM DIFFERENT
INFORMATION FOR WHAT WAS GIVEN
TO THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES
AND WHEN THEY RECONVENED, KEEP
IN MIND THIS IS MORE THAN JUST
SENATORS.
MEANS STAFF AND U.S. CAPITOL
POLICE OFFICERS, THIS IS WHAT
WORRIES DEMOCRATIC SENATOR FROM
MARYLAND.
>> I AM VERY WORRIED ABOUT ALL
THE CAPITAL STAFF AND PUTTING
THEIR HEALTH AND LIVES AT RISK,
AND I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
SENATOR McCONNELL PUTS IN
PLACE ADEQUATE PROTECTIONS TO
MAKE SURE THE SENATE DOESN’T
BECOME A VECTOR FOR THE
CORONAVIRUS.
>> THE HOUSE AND SENATE RARELY
AGREE ON A MUCH INCLUDING WHEN
EACH BODY SHOULD MEET DURING THE
PANDEMIC, ORIGINALLY PLANNED TO
MEET NEXT WEEK BUT DEMOCRATIC
LEADERS RETREATED.
AND EXPRESSED CONCERNS ABOUT THE
HOUSE RETURNING AS NUMBERS IN
WASHINGTON, D.C., ARE DROPPING
YET.
AND IT’S LITTLE SURPRISE THAT IN
CONGRESS RETURNING TO SESSION AS
A DEMOCRAT VERSUS REPUBLICAN
ISSUE.
>> GOTTEN GUIDANCE FROM THE
ATTENDING PHYSICIAN, AND I’M A
PHYSICIAN AND I AGREE WITH WHAT
WE ARE GOING TO BE DOING
STARTING MONDAY IN THE SENATE.
>> ON MONDAY, THEY WILL HAVE ONE
CONFIRMATION VOTE.
IT’S A LOW LEVEL NOMINATION AND
ALSO HEARINGS THIS WEEK, ONE ON
THE CRISIS FACING AIRLINES AND
ALSO WE HEARING ABOUT TESTING
AND A CONFIRMATION NEXT WEEK
CONFIRMING JOHN RATCLIFFE, THE